The practice of meditation dates back thousands of years and is a part of nearly every major religion. But it's only in the past several decades that researchers have begun to use the tools of modern science to explore what's happening in the brains of people while they meditate, and to measure how meditation can benefit our minds and bodies. In our cacophonous modern world, full of distractions, stress, and anxiety, can these ancient practices help us to flourish? And if so, how? What are the different types of meditation?
冥想的实践已有数千年的历史，几乎是每个主要宗教的一部分。但直到过去几十年，研究人员才开始利用现代科学的工具来探索人们在冥想时大脑中发生了什么，并衡量冥想如何有益于我们的身心。在你我这个充满干扰、压力和焦虑的嘈杂现代世界中，这些古老的实践能帮助我们蓬勃发展吗？如果可以，又是如何做到的？冥想有哪些不同的类型？
What are the benefits of each? Can you, should you, try it at home? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. Our guest today is Dr. Richard Davidson, a professor of psychology at the University of Wisconsin-Madison,
每种类型都有什么好处？你可以在家里尝试吗？你应该尝试吗？欢迎收听《心理学说话》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学协会（American Psychological Association）的旗舰播客，探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。我们今天的嘉宾是威斯康星大学麦迪逊分校心理学教授理查德·戴维森博士（Dr. Richard Davidson），
and founder and director of the University's Center for Healthy Minds. Dr. Davidson has spent decades studying meditation as both a practitioner and a scientist. He's worked with the Dalai Lama and hundreds of other master meditators to understand how meditation can shape the mind and promote well-being. His center also works to develop meditation-based interventions for children. In addition, he's well known for his research on emotion, emotional styles, and the neural basis of emotion.
同时他也是该校健康心灵中心（Center for Healthy Minds）的创始人兼主任。戴维森博士作为一名实践者和科学家，花费了数十年时间研究冥想。他曾与达赖喇嘛以及其他数百位冥想大师合作，以了解冥想如何塑造心灵并促进幸福感。他的中心还致力于为儿童开发基于冥想的干预措施。此外，他在情绪、情绪风格以及情绪的神经基础等研究领域也享有盛誉。
Dr. Davidson has published hundreds of scientific papers and several books, including his most recent, Altered Traits, Science Reveals How Meditation Changes Your mind, brain, and body. Thank you for joining us today, Dr. Davidson. It's a pleasure to be here. Thank you for having me. Our listeners probably have some idea of what we mean when we talk about meditation. But you've said that meditation is like sports. It's a broader term than many people realize. Can you explain that? What are the different forms of meditation that people might not be familiar with? Well, I do use the analogy with sports because there are literally hundreds of
戴维森博士发表了数百篇科学论文和几本书，其中包括他最近的著作《改变的特质：科学揭示冥想如何改变你的心灵、大脑和身体》（Altered Traits, Science Reveals How Meditation Changes Your Mind, Brain, and Body）。非常感谢您今天加入我们，戴维森博士。很高兴来到这里。谢谢邀请我。我们的 listeners（听众）在谈到冥想时，可能对它的含义有一些概念。但您曾说过，冥想就像体育运动。它是一个比许多人意识到的更广泛的术语。您能解释一下吗？人们可能不太熟悉的不同形式的冥想有哪些？嗯，我确实用了体育运动这个类比，因为从字面上看，有数百种
different kinds of meditation practices. And we are only familiar with a very small sector of them here in the West. And what has received attention from the scientific community is a small sliver of meditation practices. In the classical traditions, the word meditation literally means familiarization. It means to familiarize ourselves with the basic nature of our own minds. And there are practices for many different kinds of characteristics. There are practices to cultivate basic qualities of attention and awareness.
不同种类的冥想实践。在西方，我们只熟悉其中非常小的一部分。而受到科学界关注的也只是冥想实践的一小部分。在传统流派中，冥想这个词的字面意思是“熟悉化”。这意味着让我们熟悉自己心灵的基本性质。有针对许多不同特质的练习。有些练习旨在培养注意力和觉察的基本品质。
There are practices to cultivate loving kindness and compassion. There are practices that are. known as analytic meditation, which have received virtually no attention here in the West. And this is the kind of practice that the Dalai Lama typically does, for example. And they intentionally use thinking and reasoning as part of meditation to come to some deep understanding of the basic nature of our own mind. And so there are literally all these varied kinds of practices, and what they share in common is a technology, if you will,
有些练习旨在培养慈悲心和同情心。还有些被称为分析性冥想的练习，在西方几乎没有受到任何关注。例如，这正是达赖喇嘛通常会做的练习。它们在冥想中刻意运用思考和推理，以便对我们心灵的基本性质有深刻的理解。因此，确实存在着所有这些形形色色的练习，它们的共同点是一项技术——如果你愿意这么称呼的话——
to promote human flourishing, a technology to learn the fundamental skills of well-being. That's really what they're intended for. Of all these meditation practices you describe, mindfulness is probably one many of our listeners would be familiar with. Why has mindfulness meditation in particular become so well known? I think mindfulness meditation has become so well known in part for historical reasons. It was one of the first forms of traditional Asian-style meditation that was taught in the West. Also, John Cabot-Zinn, a very dear friend and colleague, developed a standardized instruction called Mindfulness-Based Stress Reduction that has been taught at academic medical centers throughout the U.S. and in most parts of the Western world.
旨在促进人类的蓬勃发展，这是一项学习幸福之基本技能的技术。这确实是它们的初衷。在您描述的所有这些冥想实践中，正念可能是我们的许多听众都熟悉的一种。为什么正念冥想尤其变得如此广为人知？我认为正念冥想之所以变得如此广为人知，部分原因是历史原因。它是西方教授的早期传统亚洲风格冥想形式之一。此外，我的挚友兼同事约翰·卡巴金（Jon Kabat-Zinn）开发了一套名为“正念减压疗法”的标准化教学法，该疗法已在美国各地的学术医疗中心以及西方世界的大多数地区得到教授。
And this is a very convenient form of mindfulness meditation that is packaged in a very standardized format and can be taught very easily. And this has helped to, I think, increase the availability and therefore the popularity of mindfulness-based practices. You've practiced meditation yourself since the 1970s when you were in grad school. and you've written about how it's always been an important part of your life. But it wasn't part of your academic research for the first couple of decades in your career. And I understand it was actually the Dalai Lama who inspired your research in this area. Can you talk, tell us that story? Certainly I'd be happy to.
这是一种非常方便的正念冥想形式，采用高度标准化的包装，可以非常容易地教授。我认为这有助于提高正念实践的可及性，进而提升其受欢迎程度。您自己从20世纪70年代读研究生起就开始实践冥想了，
So I became interested in meditation very early on in my career. I had the opportunity to be around some people who, were meditators and they just impressed me with their demeanor. They were very warm-hearted people, really friendly. They were the kind of people I wanted to be around and they weren't for the most part my professors in graduate school. There were folks I met on the outside and they all had in common this interest in practice of meditation. And that's what led me to explore this in the first place. And I actually did do some research very early on in my career and actually published some of that in the 1970s on meditation, but it was made very clear to me by my professors at that time
您也曾撰文谈到它如何一直是您生活中重要的一部分。但在您职业生涯的前几十年里，它并不是您学术研究的一部分。据我了解，实际上是达赖喇嘛激发了您在该领域的研究所。您能讲讲那个故事吗？当然，我很乐意讲。所以我很早就对冥想产生了兴趣。我有机会接触到一些练习冥想的人，他们的风度给我留下了深刻的印象。他们是非常热心肠的人，真的很友好。他们是我愿意与之交往的那种人，而且他们绝大多数都不是我在研究生院的教授。他们是我在外面遇到的人，他们都有一个共同点，那就是对冥想实践的兴趣。正是这一点促使我首先探索这个领域。事实上，我在职业生涯的早期确实做过一些研究，并且在20世纪70年代发表了一些关于冥想的研究，但当时的教授向我明确表示，
that if I wanted a successful career in science, that was a terrible way to begin. And I better find some other topic. And so I was actually a very dutiful student, and that's when I began to pursue research on the brain and emotion and kept my interest in meditation very much under the radar. And then when I met the Dalai Lama for the first time was in 1992, and he very directly challenged me. And he said, look, you've been using tools of modern neuroscience to study stress and anxiety and depression. Why can't you use those same tools to study kindness and to study compassion? and I didn't have a very good answer for him, but it was a wake-up call, and that was the beginning of a major pivot
如果我想在科学界获得成功的职业生涯，那将是一个糟糕的开端。我最好找点别的课题。所以实际上我是一个非常听话的学生，正是在那个时候，我开始从事大脑和情绪方面的研究，并将我对冥想的兴趣深深地隐藏在幕后。然后我于1992年第一次见到了达赖喇嘛，他非常直接地向我提出了挑战。他说，听着，你一直在用现代神经科学的工具来研究压力、焦虑和抑郁。为什么你不能用同样的工具来研究善良和同情心呢？我当时答不上来，但这对我来说是一个警钟，那也是我们工作中重大转变的开始，
that we made in our work and oriented more toward the positive qualities of our nature and how they can be cultivated. What happened with those professors who were so discouraging? Have you spoken to them since? Some of them. You know, I think some of them came around and some of them, you know, ended their careers in a way that I think is a little bit close-minded. But now, if you look at textbooks of psychology or hard-nosed journals, the best journals in the world, really, they are publishing work in this area. And one of the commitments I made to the Dalai Lama in 1992 is I was going to do everything I could to put compassion squarely within the crosshairs of rigorous science.
我们的工作开始更多地转向我们天性中的积极品质以及如何培养这些品质。那些曾经极力泼冷水的教授们后来怎么样了？您后来跟他们说过话吗？其中一些人。你知道，我认为他们中的一些人后来转变了态度，而另一些人，你知道，他们职业生涯的结局在我看来有点思想闭塞。但现在，如果你看看心理学教科书或严谨的期刊，世界上最好的期刊，真的，他们都在发表这个领域的研究成果。我在1992年对达赖喇嘛做出过承诺之一，就是我要尽我所能，将同情心置于严谨科学的精准审视之下。
And if you go back to textbooks of psychology in the early 1990s and 1980s, you won't see the word compassion in the index. And that's changed. That's really changed. And so I am very deeply grateful to see how quickly actually progress has been made. So in the intervening years, I guess since you met the Dalai Lama, you've brought hundreds of Buddhist monks and other expert meditators into your lab to study how their brains work. What are the differences you find among long-term meditators, novice meditators, and people who have never tried the practice?
如果你翻看20世纪90年代初和80年代的心理学教科书，你在索引里是找不到“同情心”这个词的。情况已经变了。真的变了。因此，看到科学进步的步伐如此之快，我内心深感感激。所以在随后的几年里，我想自从你见到达赖喇嘛以来，你已经把数百名佛教僧侣和其他冥想专家请进实验室，研究他们的大脑是如何运作的。在长期冥想者、新手冥想者以及从未尝试过冥想的人之间，你发现了什么不同？
Well, that's a great question, and it's difficult to answer in a specific way because it really depends on the nature of the practice. It depends on whether we're looking at the brain while people are meditating or at baseline. But there are few things that are general characteristics that are worth pointing out. And this is based on both our own research as well as the research of other scientists. One is that we now know that we can use certain structural parameters of the brain to estimate a person's brain age. So all of our brains are aging. Some people have brains that are aging faster than their chronological age.
嗯，这是一个很好的问题，而且很难给出具体的回答，因为它真的取决于练习的性质。这取决于我们是在人们冥想时还是在基线状态下观察大脑。但有几个共同的特征值得指出。这是基于我们自己的研究以及其他科学家的研究。首先，我们现在知道，我们可以利用大脑的某些结构参数来估计一个人的大脑年龄。所以我们的大脑都在老化。有些人的大脑老化速度比他们的实际年龄要快，
other people have brains that are aging more slowly compared to their chronological age. If you take a thousand people and you look at the correlation between their brain age and their chronological age, you'll see it's a very high correlation. But there are some people that are off the diagonal, that is whose brains are aging more quickly or more slowly compared to their chronological age. It turns out that long-term meditators have brains that are aging. more slowly compared to their chronological age. And so in a very real way, we can say that these practices are beneficial for our brain
而另一些人的大脑老化速度比他们的实际年龄要慢。如果你随机抽取一千个人，观察他们的大脑年龄与实际年龄之间的相关性，你会发现这是一个非常高的相关性。但有些人偏离了对角线，也就是说，与他们的实际年龄相比，他们的大脑老化得更快或更慢。事实证明，长期冥想者的老龄化速度比他们的实际年龄要慢。因此，在非常真实的意义上，我们可以说这些练习有益于我们的大脑
health, and they actually help us to cope with the age-related changes in a more adaptive way. The second thing that we can say in a general way is that we can say in a general way is that we that circuits in the brain that are important for self-regulation are strengthened. So what might be included within self-regulation? Well, one is the capacity to regulate our attention, which is, it's so important, it's really difficult to overestimate how important this is. We are living in a culture today where our attention is being continuously captured by the forces around us.
健康，它们实际上能帮助我们以更具适应性的方式应对与年龄相关的变化。我们可以概括的第二件事是，我们可以概括地说，大脑中对自我调节至关重要的神经回路得到了加强。那么，自我调节中可能包括什么呢？嗯，其中之一就是调节我们注意力的能力，这一点非常重要，怎么强调它的重要性都不为过。我们生活在这样一个文化中：我们的注意力正不断被周围的力量所捕获。
The media, particularly social media and technology, have become expert in attention capture. And we critically need to educate our own minds and brains so that we can regulate our own attention and not cede it over to the media to all these forces that we never gave our consent to. And, you know, we're all pawns in this grand social experiment for which none of us have provided our consent. And unless we take better control of our own minds, we're going to be in trouble. And so this is an invitation to
媒体，尤其是社交媒体和科技，已经成为注意力捕获方面的专家。我们迫切需要教育我们自己的心灵和大脑，以便我们能够调节自己的注意力，而不是把它拱手让给媒体，让给所有这些我们从未同意过的力量。而且，你知道，我们都是这场宏大社会实验中的棋子，而我们当中没有一个人为此提供过同意。除非我们更好地控制自己的心灵，否则我们将陷入困境。所以这是一个邀请，
learn the skills of self-regulation. And so regulating attention is one big domain. And let me mention just a second related domain, which is the regulation of emotion. The prevalence of disorders of emotion is skyrocketing. And it's only been exacerbated by the pandemic. And we need to learn the skills of how to better regulate our emotions in order to more successfully adapt to the modern world. And meditation provides us with some simple tools to learn these skills of self-regulation. So by disorders of emotion, do you mean things like stress, anxiety, depression, those sorts of things? Exactly, exactly. You and other resources, researchers have found some evidence that meditation can change a person's brain structure,
去学习自我调节的技能。因此，调节注意力是一个重要领域。请允许我提及第二个相关领域，那就是情绪调节。情绪障碍的患病率正在急剧上升。大流行病更是雪上加霜。我们需要学习如何更好地调节情绪的技能，以便更成功地适应现代世界。冥想为我们提供了一些简单的工具来学习这些自我调节的技能。那么，说到情绪障碍，你的意思是像压力、焦虑、抑郁这些事情吗？完全正确，完全正确。你和其他资源研究人员发现了一些证据，表明冥想可以改变人的大脑结构，
but you've also urged caution in interpreting those results. Why the caution? Well, there is a scientific literature on the impact of meditation on changing brain structure. And, you know, when you reflect on this work, there are a number of important considerations. One, is that let's say that we take a finding that shows that a particular area the brain may be enlarged through meditation, actually grow in size. Well, it seems to strain the conceptual possibility to think that as you continue to develop more and more expertise, that that area the brain will become larger and larger. It just, you know, if that were the case, people who are, some of the monks we've tested who've had, you know, 50,000 hours of practice should really have unusually
但你也敦促在解释这些结果时要保持谨慎。为什么要保持谨慎？嗯，确实有关于冥想对改变大脑结构影响的科学文献。而且，当你反思这项工作时，有许多重要的考量。首先，比方说我们发现了一个证据，表明通过冥想，大脑的某个特定区域可能会变大，实际上尺寸会增长。嗯，随着你不断培养越来越多的专业知识，认为大脑的那一部分会变得越来越大，这种概念上的可能性似乎有些勉强。这只是，你知道，如果是那样的话，我们测试过的一些僧侣——他们有50,000小时的练习经历——他们的大脑在那些特定区域真的应该异常
large areas of the brain in those specific regions. They don't. There's no evidence to show that they do. And so it may well be. that there are curvilinear relationships that are very complex and so when we're first learning some of these skills for example the skills of self-regulation certain areas of the prefrontal cortex which are important for this may become enlarged but then after they become more automatic after these skills are learned at a more at a greater level of expertise it may be be that these areas of the brain begin to recede back to what they were. And so it's,
巨大。他们并没有。没有证据表明他们有这样的情况。所以很可能存在着非常复杂的非线性关系，因此当我们刚开始学习其中的一些技能时，例如自我调节的技能，对此很重要的前额叶皮层的某些区域可能会变大；但随后，在它们变得更加自动化之后，在这些技能以更高的专业水平被掌握之后，大脑的这些区域可能开始回缩到它们原本的大小。所以，
it's not possible for an area of the brain to just keep getting larger and larger. It doesn't make any sense. Well, it's limited, limited by your skull, right? I mean, you can only get so big. Absolutely. So there are all these constraints. So the, just based on first principles, it doesn't make any sense that an area is just going to keep getting larger. And so, the other thing is just there are a lot of methodological problems with this research. And the sample sizes have typically been small. And there is some reason for healthy skepticism, in my opinion, based on the current state of the evidence. Can anyone learn to meditate or are there some people who just cannot?
大脑的某个区域不可能一直变大。这毫无道理。嗯，它受到你的头骨的限制，对吧？我的意思是，它只能长那么大。绝对的。所以存在着所有这些限制。因此，仅从第一性原理来看，大脑某个区域会一直变大的说法是毫无道理的。另外，这项研究还存在很多方法论问题。样本量通常也很小。在我看来，根据目前的证据状况，保持健康的怀疑态度是有理由的。任何人都可以学会冥想吗？还是有些人就是学不会？
And are some people better at it than others? Is it sort of a talent like some people have musical ability? or they're really good at math? That's an important question. I would say that every person with a normal brain, so to speak, is capable of meditating. That is a brain without any kind of frank damage. You know, it may well be that, I mean, I've met lots of people who tell me that they can't meditate.
有些人比其他人更有天赋吗？这有点像某种天赋，就像有些人有音乐天赋，或者他们擅长数学一样？这是一个重要的问题。我想说，可以说每个拥有正常大脑的人都有能力冥想。也就是说，一个没有任何明显损伤的大脑。你知道，很有可能，我的意思是，我遇到过很多人告诉我他们无法冥想。
And I say to them, well, can you pay attention right now to the sensation of your breathing? Or can you listen to this sound and know that you're hearing this sound? And they'll say, of course, I could do that. And I'll say, well, you were just meditating. It is that simple. It really is that simple. And when a person says they can't meditate, what they're typically referring to is they can't sit still for a very long period of time. They can't, their attention is very scattered. And that's okay. That's the way, human minds often are. And so meditation fundamentally is really about awareness. And so if we can bring awareness to our chaotic mind, that's meditation. And what I encourage people to do is to start
我对他们说，嗯，你现在能把注意力集中在呼吸的感觉上吗？或者你能听到这个声音并知道你在听这个声音吗？他们会说，当然，我能做到。然后我会说，嗯，你刚才就是在冥想。就是这么简单。真的就是这么简单。当一个人说他们无法冥想时，他们通常指的是他们无法长时间保持坐姿。他们不能，他们的注意力非常分散。这没关系。人类的心灵往往就是这个样子的。因此，冥想从根本上来说确实是关于觉察的。所以如果我们能把觉察带到我们混乱的心灵中，那就是冥想。我鼓励人们做的是，从
very modestly with very short periods of time, even one minute or two minutes that you can sprinkle through a day. And that's how this kind of skill and habit can be slowly built up. Are there tools that people can use? Should they go to your website and look for things in order to learn how to practice meditation? Or what about apps? Are there just methods that people can find out there, whether for free or for pay, that would help them become meditators or better meditators? Well, we have developed an app in our center through an affiliated nonprofit that I founded. And the app is called the Healthy Minds Program, and it's entirely free. So there are absolutely no paywalls.
非常适度的、很短的时间开始，甚至是一分钟或两分钟，你可以把它穿插在一整天里。这就是这种技能和习惯如何慢慢建立起来的方法。人们可以使用什么工具吗？他们应该去你的网站寻找东西来学习如何练习冥想吗？或者应用程序呢？有没有人们可以找到的免费或付费的方法，可以帮助他们成为冥想者或更好的冥想者？嗯，我们在我们中心通过我创立的一个附属非营利组织开发了一款应用程序。这款应用程序叫做“健康心灵计划”（Healthy Minds Program），它是完全免费的。所以绝对没有任何付费墙。
You can download it from wherever you get apps. You can also go to the website, Try Healthy Minds. So all one word, try healthy minds.org, and learn more about it. This is an app that provides a very comprehensive training in each of the four pillars of well-being that exhibit plasticity that we know can be trained through this kind of method. And so I would encourage people who are interested, please try it. You really have nothing to lose. It's entirely free, as I said, and we'd love to hear from you.
无论你在哪里下载应用程序都可以获取它。你也可以访问网站 Try Healthy Minds。所以全部连在一起，tryhealthyminds.org，了解更多信息。这是一个提供非常全面训练的应用程序，涵盖了我们所知的可以通过这种方法进行训练的、表现出可塑性的四个幸福支柱。因此，我鼓励感兴趣的人们去尝试一下。你真的没有什么可失去的。正如我所说，它是完全免费的，我们很乐意听到你的反馈。
So you mentioned the four pillars of well-being. I wanted to ask you about that. What are they? And how can people work toward achieving them? So the four pillars of well-being constitute a framework that we've written about in our scientific work, and that guides a lot of our research and also guides the interventions that we're developing, including in this app that I've described.
你提到了幸福的四个支柱。我想问你关于这个的问题。它们是什么？人们如何努力去实现它们？所以幸福的四个支柱构成了一个框架，我们在科学工作中写过这个框架，它指导了我们的许多研究，也指导了我们正在开发的干预措施，包括在这个我描述的应用程序中。
The four pillars are these. The first pillar is awareness, and awareness is where mindfulness would be. It includes our capacity to regulate our attention, and it also includes what scientists call meta-awareness, which is knowing what our minds are doing. That may sound strange to some listeners. Don't we always know what our minds are doing?
这四个支柱是这样的。第一个支柱是觉察，觉察就是正念所在的地方。它包括我们调节注意力的能力，它还包括科学家所说的元觉察，也就是知道我们的心灵在做什么。这听取某些听众可能会觉得奇怪。难道我们不是一直都知道我们的心灵在做什么吗？
Well, I think many of us have had the experience, I certainly have, of reading a book where you might be reading each word on a page and you read one page, maybe a second page, maybe even a third page. And after a few minutes, you realize you have absolutely no idea what you've just read. Your mind is somewhere else. That's an example of not knowing what our minds are doing. But the moment we recognize that, that's a moment of meta-awareness, and we can bring our mind back to the present moment. So that's the first pillar of awareness.
嗯，我想我们很多人都有过这样的经历，我当然有过，就是在读书时，你可能在读页面上的每一个字，你读了一页，也许是第二页，甚至可能是第三页。几分钟后，你意识到你根本不知道自己刚读了什么。你的心灵在别的地方。这就是不知道我们的心灵在做什么的一个例子。但就在我们认识到那一刻起，这就是元觉察的时刻，我们可以把心灵带回到当下。所以这是觉察的第一个支柱。
The second pillar is called connection, and it is about the qualities which are important for healthy social relationships. Qualities like appreciation and gratitude and kindness and compassion. And we know from hard-nosed scientific research that these can be trained, and training in these qualities helps to change the brain. The third pillar of well-being is called insight. And this is about getting curious about the nature of ourselves. It's really about self-knowledge. We all have a narrative about ourselves that we carry around in our mind.
第二个支柱称为连接，它是关于对健康社会关系至关重要的品质。诸如欣赏、感恩、善良和同情心等品质。我们从严谨的科学研究中得知，这些品质是可以训练的，对这些品质的训练有助于改变大脑。幸福的第三个支柱被称为洞察。这是关于对我们自身本性保持好奇。这实际上是关于自我认知。我们每个人都有一个在心灵中随身携带的关于自己的叙事。
Some people have a very negative narrative. They have negative self-beliefs and they actually hold. those beliefs to be an accurate description of who they are. And of course, that's a prescription for depression. And so part of well-being is having a deep understanding of this narrative and recognizing how the narrative may constrain our perception of the world, constrain how we attend to the world, and having that insight can liberate us in a way. away from these constraints and is conducive to well-being. And finally, the last pillar of well-being is purpose.
有些人有一个非常消极的叙事。他们有消极的自我信念，并且他们实际上坚信这些信念是对他们是谁的准确描述。当然，这是通往抑郁的处方。因此，幸福的一部分是对这个叙事有深刻的理解，并认识到这个叙事如何限制我们对世界的感知，限制我们如何关注世界，而拥有这种洞察力可以某种程度上解放我们，
And purpose is not so much about going to find your true purpose, but really discovering your sense of direction in life and then orienting more and more of your everyday behavior around this sense of purpose. So can you envision that even menial kinds of tasks that, even menial kinds of tasks that, you, that you do on a daily basis, can you envision that being related to your sense of purpose? Can you envision that taking out the garbage and cleaning your house is related
摆脱这些限制，并且有利于幸福。最后，幸福的最后一个支柱是目标。目标与其说是去寻找你的真正目标，不如说是真正发现你在生活中的方向感，然后将越来越多的日常行为围绕着这种目标感进行定向。所以你能想象吗，即使是日常生活中那些微不足道的任务，甚至是你每天做的那些微不足道的任务，你能想象这与你的目标感有关吗？你能想象倒垃圾和打扫房间是与
to your deepest sense of purpose? It's possible to do that. And so that can be trained, and that will have a very powerful effect on our well-being. So those are the four pillars of well-being, each of which exhibits plasticity, each can be trained, And there is simple meditation practices that you can use to train each of these four pillars.
你最深层的目标感有关吗？这是有可能做到的。所以这是可以训练的，并且这会对我们的幸福产生非常强大的影响。这就是幸福的四个支柱，每一个都表现出可塑性，每一个都可以被训练，并且你可以使用简单的冥想实践来训练这四个支柱中的每一个。
How long might it take a novice meditator to see the kinds of changes that we're talking about? Or is this way to individual centered for you to be able to give even a ballpark? Well, I'm not sure which changes you're referring to. But if you're talking about changes in the brain, seven hours of practice. That's not much. Not much. Half hour a day for two weeks. You can see changes in the brain. We've demonstrated that in rigorous, randomized control trials. It doesn't mean these changes will stick. You know, if you go to the gym and work out with a trainer for two weeks, you will see changes in your body. But if you stop exercising for the rest of your life, you obviously will not have those changes endure. The same thing is true. in this realm. The invitation here is to provide people with simple lifelong skills that they can continue to practice. There's been a resurgence of research into the use of psychedelics for mind
新手冥想者可能需要多长时间才能看到我们所谈论的那种改变？还是这种方法过于以个人为中心，以至于你无法给出一个大概的估算？嗯，我不确定你指的是哪种改变。但如果你谈论的是大脑的变化，七个小时的练习。这并不多。不多。每天半小时，持续两周。你就可以看到大脑的变化。我们已经通过严谨的随机对照试验展示了这一点。这并不意味着这些变化会一直保持下去。你知道，如果你去健身房跟教练锻炼两周，你会看到身体发生变化。但如果你余生停止锻炼，你显然不会让这些变化持续下去。同样的道理也适用于这个领域。
expansion and well-being recently. We did a podcast on it last year. And one thing that researchers have found is that psychedelics may provide some of the same experiences and effects as long-term meditation practice does. What's your view as psychedelics as a road toward achieving well-being? My view is a nuanced view. So I am firmly supportive of investigating the application of psychedelics for individuals who are suffering, who have certain kinds of intractable disorders that have been unresponsive to other kinds of treatment. So, for example, patients with certain kinds of depression, with anxiety, patients who are terminally ill, and facing the prospect of impending death, these are all cases where I think there may well be
这里的邀请是为人们提供简单的终身技能，他们可以继续练习。最近，关于使用迷幻剂来拓展思维和促进幸福的研究出现了复苏。我们去年做过一期关于这个的播客。研究人员发现的一件事是，迷幻剂可能会提供与长期冥想实践相同的一些体验和效果。你对迷幻剂作为通往幸福之路的看法是什么？我的看法是有细微差别的。所以我坚决支持研究迷幻剂对那些正在受苦、患有某种难治性疾病且对其他治疗无效的个人的应用。例如，患有特定抑郁症、焦虑症的患者，身患绝症、面临迫在死神威胁的患者，在所有这些情况下，我认为迷幻剂可能发挥非常有用作用。对于那些走在幸福之旅上、并没有明确遭受某种疾病折磨的人来说，我持怀疑态度，迷幻剂是否会带来持久的改变。它们可能有助于让人稍微敞开心扉，扩大他们对可能性的认识，在个别情况下这可能会有所帮助，但我同时也看到了存在某些危险的可能性。所以，你知道，我们在冥想中学到的一件事是，你知道，
a very useful role for psychedelics. For people who are on a journey of well-being, who are not explicitly suffering from a disorder, I am skeptical that psychedelics will lead to enduring change. They may be helpful in opening a person up a little bit and expanding their sense of what is possible, and that might be in individual cases helpful, but I also see the possibility of some danger as well. And so, you know, one of the things that we learn in meditation is, you know,
有时对于一个每天冥想的人来说，并非每一次冥想练习都是积极的。它不可能一直都处于极乐状态。有时当你审视自己的心灵时，你会看到很多分心，很多负面想法，这并不是那么令人愉快。但你学到的事情之一是，这不是关于体验。当你审视分心的心灵和所有负面想法时，冥想实践的价值与你有一次积极的体验时是一样的，甚至可能更有益。
sometimes for a person that meditates daily, not every meditation session is going to be, you know, positive. It's not going to be blissful all the time. Sometimes when you look at it. your mind, you'll see a lot of distraction, a lot of negative thoughts, and it's not so pleasant. But one of the things you learn is that it's not about the experience. The value of a meditation practice where you're looking at your distracted mind and all the negative thoughts, it's just as beneficial as if you have a positive session, maybe even more
所以这不是关于体验。你知道，我的一个冥想老师说过，冥想时的心灵就像股市。它时涨时跌。但它不是，它，这与它是涨是跌毫无关系。这与你在冥想时获得的体验无关。这关乎它如何影响你日常生活中的每一个角落。因此，我认为迷幻剂的危险在于，你会变得非常依恋在药物诱发效应期间所获得的体验。而这并不一定是积极的。在经历了这么多年的这个领域的工作之后，接下来是什么？你和其他人还有什么留待探索的？嗯，还有很多留待探索。关于这些类型的实践如何影响大脑和身体，还有很多基础研究。
beneficial. And so it's not about the experience. You know, one of my meditation teachers said the mind during meditation is like the stock market. It goes up and down. But it's not, it's, it has nothing to do with whether it's up or down. It's not about the experience you have when you're meditating. It's about how it affects every nook and cranny of your everyday life. And so the danger, I think, with psychedelics is you become very attached to the experience that you have during the drug-induced effects. And that is not necessarily positive. After all these years of working in this field, what's next and what is left for you and others to be looking at? Well, there's a lot left. There's a lot of basic research about how these kinds of practices affect the brain and the body.
有很多关于表观遗传学效应的研究，也就是这些实践可能带来的基因表达的变化，这对健康会产生一些非常重要的影响。有很多关于炎症的研究，不仅是身体上的炎症，还有可能导致神经退行性疾病的大脑炎症，这是一个在老龄化人口中冥想可能非常有帮助的领域。但同时也有很多实际问题。我们不知道将这些实践带给大量人群并扩大规模的最佳策略是什么。例如，如果一个人打算每天分配15分钟开始练习，
There's a lot of work that's going on on epigenetic effects, that is changes in gene expression that may be brought about by these practices, which can have some really important effects on health. There's a lot of work going on inflammation, not just inflammation in the body, but also inflammation in the brain that may contribute to neurodegenerative diseases. and this is an area where meditation may be very helpful in an aging population. But then there are also a lot of practical questions. We don't know what the best strategy is to bring these practices to large groups of people to scale them. If a person, for example, is going to allocate 15 minutes a day to start practicing,
是分一次15分钟练习更好？还是分三次5分钟练习，或者分五次3分钟练习？这个问题从来没有被问过，更不用说被回答了。而我的直觉是，对于不同类型的人来说，这很可能是不同的。有些人会从非常短时间的练习中受益。另一些人可能会从较长时间的练习中受益。这些都是重要的问题，而我们目前还没有答案。我认为这是一个重要的科学研究领域，将在未来几年内开展，并将有助于解决这些问题。
is it better that they do it in one 15 minute period? in three, five-minute periods or in five, three-minute periods. That question has never even been asked, let alone answered. And my intuition is it's likely going to be different for different kinds of people. Some people will benefit from very short periods of practice. Other people may benefit from a longer period of practice. These are all important questions for which we do not have answers. And this is an area where I think there'll be some important scientific research that will be done over the next few years that will help address this.
这真的非常有趣。戴维森博士，非常感谢您今天抽出时间与我们交谈。谢谢。不客气。很高兴。您可以在我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org 或您获取播客的任何地方找到《心理学说话》（Speaking of Psychology）的往期节目。如果您对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，请发电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。
This has been really interesting. Dr. Davidson, I appreciate your taking the time to talk to us today. Thank you. You're most welcome. Pleasure. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingof psychology.org or wherever you get your podcasts. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, email us. us at Speaking of Psychology at APA.org.
那是 Speaking of Psychology，全部连在一起，发邮件至 apa.org。《心理学说话》（Speaking of Psychology）由李·威纳曼（Lee Winerman）制作。我们的声音编辑是克里斯·孔达扬（Chris Kondayan）。感谢您收听美国心理学协会的节目。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。
That's Speaking of Psychology, all one word, at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Winerman. Our sound editor is Chris Kondayan. Thank you for listening for the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这就是Speaking of Psychology，所有字母连在一起，网址是APA.org。Speaking of Psychology由李·威纳曼制作。我们的音频编辑是克里斯·孔达扬。感谢您收听美国心理学会的节目。我是金·米尔斯。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。